when you look up at the
stars uh and think big what do you hope
is the future of humanity hundreds
thousands of years from now out in
space I would love to see you know a you
know a trillion humans living in the
solar system if we had a trillion humans
we would have in any given time a
thousand mozarts and a thousand
Einstein um that would you know our
source system would be full of life and
intelligence and energy um and we can
easily support a civilization that large
with all of the resources um in the
solar system so what do you think that
looks like giant space stations yeah the
only way to get to that vision is with
giant space stations you know the
planetary surfaces are just way too
small um so you can I mean unless you
turn them into giant space stations or
something but but yeah we will take
materials from the Moon and from near
Earth objects and from the asteroid belt
and so on and will build uh giant O'Neal
style colonies um and people will live
in those and they have a lot of
advantages over planetary surfaces you
can spin them to get normal Earth
gravity you can put them where you want
them I think most people are going to
want to live uh near Earth not
necessarily an Earth orbit but in you
know uh Earth but near Earth vicinity uh
orbits so they can move Qui you know
relatively quickly uh back and forth
between their station and Earth so I
don't I think a lot of people especially
in the early stages are not going to
want to give up Earth altogether they go
to Earth for vacation yeah same way that
you know you might go to to Yellowstone
National Park for vacation people will
uh and the ADV and no one and people get
to choose where they live on earth or
they live in space but they'll be able
to use much more energy and much more
material resource in space than they
would be able to use on Earth one of the
interesting ideas you had is to move the
heavy industry away from Earth so people
sometimes have this idea that somehow
space
exploration is in conflict with the
celebration of the planet Earth that we
should focus on preserving Earth and and
basically your idea is that space travel
and space exploration is a way to
preserve Earth exactly this planet we've
sent otic probes to all the planets we
know that this is the good
one yeah not the play favorites or
anything but but Earth really is the
good Planet it's an amaz it's it's
amazing the ecosystem we have here all
of the life and the Lush uh plant life
and you know the Water Resources
everything this planet is really
extraordinary and of course we evolved
on this planet so of course it's perfect
for us but it's also perfect for all the
advanced life forms on this planet all
the animals and so on and so this is a
gym we do need to take care of it and as
we enter the anthropos as we get as we
humans have gotten so uh sophisticated
and large and impactful as we stride
across this planet you know it's that
that is going to as we continue we want
to use a lot of energy we want to use a
lot of energy per capita we've gotten
amazing things we we don't want to go
backwards you know if you think about
um the good old days they're mostly an
illusion like in almost every way life
is better for almost everyone today than
it was say 50 years ago or 100 years AG
we all we live better lives by and large
than our grandparents did and their
grandparents did and so on and you can
see that in global illiteracy rates
Global poverty rates Global infant
mortality rates like almost any metric
you choose we're better off than we used
to be and we get you know antibiotics
and all kinds of life-saving medical
care and so on and so on and there's one
thing that is moving backwards and it's
the natural world so it is a fact that
500 years ago pre-industrial age the
natural world was
pristine um it was incredible and we
have traded some of that pristine Beauty
for all of these other gifts that we
have as an advanced society and we can
have both but to do that we have to go
to space and all of this really the most
fundamental measure is energy usage per
capita and when you look at you know you
do want to continue to use more and more
energy it is going to make your life
better in so many ways but that's not
compatible ultimately with living on a
finite planet and so we have to go out
into the solar system uh and and really
you can argue about when you have to do
that but you can't credibly argue about
whether you have to do that eventually
we have to do that
exactly